what does elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that much burned employer solves
all of the world's major problem I
started a met Ramiz series with the goal
to try to learn from people who've done
more discuss and by hanging around an
ELISA augurs populism of their mindset
their attitudes their beliefs their
confidence keeping us to help us become
a best version of ourselves so today
we're going to learn two weeks I think
houses Purpose Driven Life
and as always times you watch this clips
to be here something that really
resonate you've seen please leave it in
quote that comes below you might win a
prize but also when you write it down
much more likely to stick with yourself
is enjoy
[Music]
we talk about living our quest and I
think that living my quest really if I
look at on a daily basis it's finding my
own voice it's finding your voice it's
finding the song that only you can sing
off-key or not it's finding your rhythm
it's discovering what it feels like to
walk in your shoes today it won't look
like it looked 10 years ago living your
quest is what can I do with my life so
that my life becomes infectious to
someone else living my quest looks like
how do I make my fingerprint matters so
big that it lives beyond my transition
day living your quest is how can I
forgive the perceiving Lea unforgivable
so I can love the absolute loveable
living your quest is how do I give
myself a thousand second chances and
every time I get to 999 press reset yeah
yeah living my quest is is not some
ambiguous untouchable experience living
my quest means going back and healing
the little girl in me so that the woman
can be free it's going back at embracing
the little boy in you so that the man
can show up and give himself permission
to cry when necessary living your quest
is not something that you can't touch
it's not something that requires a stage
or lights or cameras living your quest
as being completing content with who you
are in the dark of the night so who you
are in the middle of the day is alright
living your quest is as simple as it is
complex living your quest is about
giving yourself permission say
permission on a daily basis to become
the next best version of yourself
living your quest is not holding
yourself hostage to old decisions not
holding yourself hostage to shame blame
guilt regret and anger living your quest
is about recognizing that everyday I can
be reborn to my possibility living your
quest is as internal and personal as it
is public living your quest is about
recognizing that you have brilliance in
you and not being willing to dim your
light one more day living your quest
means not being afraid of the genius in
you even though you have doubt living
your question
recognizing that you get to sing your
song off tune that you can get to live
in perfection while you master
imperfection myth number two is that
abundance is singularly focused on
possessions and money right that's all
about what you drive what you live in
how much money you make when in fact it
couldn't be further from the truth
wealth is possessions and money
abundance is a 360 experience abundance
is a 360 experience true abundance sure
abundance is your health because if you
don't have great health life does not
feel good abundance is relationships and
at the end of your life literally you
will measure the quality of your life by
the quality of the relationships you had
all the other stuff will fall the way
that promotion you thinking about your
wonder about that race it will fall away
in the area of importance when you get
to the end of your life you will begin
to look at the quality of your
relationships how are your children
related to you how your siblings really
- do you have love in your life you
literally will start looking at
relationships at a higher level as you
get older so we mind them now you take
care of them and I know that for a fact
I have a friend who's worth 14 billion
dollars billion would it be he was just
partying at my house all night long with
leave for the morning go home and he
flew in from Canada to go to my New
Year's party because he loves my family
connection and he doesn't have one
he is financially wealthy he's
relationship broke that make sense
abundance is a 360 experience it's about
relationships it's about health it's
about your spiritual ground if that
doesn't mean you have a religious origin
it's about can you release can you
forgive can you let go can you be still
do you meditate do you have time with
yourself that has a lot to do with the
quality of your life that ability
visualization is a gift to your heart in
your soul it's a gift because if the the
idea is the seed visualization is the is
the it's the fertilizer it's the
fertilizer because when your thoughts
are connected with an emotion see you
visualize yourself winning and you will
feel all the emotion that came with that
and all you're doing now is you're not
chasing a foreign emotion you know the
feeling and now you're just doing what's
necessary to get back to that feeling in
real time work and so what what a good
friend of mine vision who of the CEO of
my value you know I would I did a
visualization with him we were in Bali
and she said to me afterwards I never
get emotional
I guess I would never get emotional
right right right right right right yeah
well he was like I cried I got emotional
because I figured out it's visualization
a good visualization brings in emotion
he was like that's how you do it and so
I love doing visualization because and
it's really important in the
visualization you can't see it over
there you have to see it right here
you're you got to feel it right here
like I am it's all I am I am I am in my
dream home I am in my dream relationship
and then unpack what that looks like
well most importantly unpack what it
feels like and when you have that that
emotion in this moment all of a sudden
you stir up something that I don't think
will ever go back to sleep it will go
okay let's go get that and what it
really does is it sets up a state of
cognitive dissonance and cognitive
dissonance is when you see something in
your mind and you see yourself in a way
that your behaviors are not currently
leading to and so your mind becomes
disrupted and
okay can we get there right on top there
right now there right now and that's not
comfortable your mind wants to literally
be congruent what it thinks is what
you're doing what it thinks is what
you're doing and so when you set up a
constant and abundant thinkers like you
and I we do it unconsciously we are
constantly keeping ourselves in a state
of cognitive dissonance meaning okay
what else and I'm seeing Lisa over there
I'm going to okay let me go while while
being grateful for my now yeah it's not
in that I'm going to be whole and
complete when I get over there I'm
holding complete now I just know I'm
supposed to be over there so let me do
what's necessary to get over there and
let me let me Vic Tanny behaviors are
characteristics that are stopping me and
let me adopt any new ones that I need
your super achievers I'm a super
achiever then one thing that to
constantly remind ourselves is to create
micro wins to get to our macro winds
that we go after the macro win but we
only look at the macro win I want you to
look at the micro wins and get 5 micro
wins under your belt so you can create
your macro in that way you celebrate
yourself a lot more often yes yes that
way you can have an indicator that
you're on the right track more often
that way your fuel is being acknowledged
more often that way you know you're on
the right track let's get to micro wins
micro wins micro wins can lead to a
macro win can we agree that that's in a
bunch I'm showing you how abundant sink
or sink so if you want to to meet you
model successful people when I was on
The Oprah Winfrey Show honor one of the
commercial breaks she said so Lisa how
many coaches do you have she didn't ask
me if I had a coach she said how many
coaches do you have I said two on the
next commercial break what you think I
did I asked her how many coaches do you
have she said four when I left the show
what do you think I did right I hired to
work offices so successful ease clues
I'm going to give you some of the clues
and people who are living an abundant
life now you guys just allow this to be
a salvo of confirmation and then for
everyone
moving in that direction and more so in
that direction these are the things that
abundant thinking people do all day
every day one we create micro lens so we
can get to macro lens and we celebrate
the micro wins far more celebrations in
life you're only going to go as far as
you think you're worthy I can push you
can push me you can have the greatest
product but if you don't feel worthy you
will work hard to sabotage that
relationship you all know it very well
you're right you don't know you're doing
you think these are the things I need
and you're driving that guy away you're
driving that woman away because your
self-worth says they weren't going to
stay forever anyway or self-worth around
money you have a cat that you feel like
you're worthy of a million dollars you
will always get to 999 the husband and
you will stop because your self-worth
says it's what's a good exercise or
process that we can follow on a daily
basis maybe something simple to enhance
our enrichment absolutely wordiness
absolutely I did this for six months
every single day right after I brush my
teeth and it's icy you exercise and you
give them here now it is not necessarily
simple because because you deliver
yourself of course and as complicated as
you are it will be the degree or
commander's override mechanics are very
well yes I appreciate that convicted you
give them air and you complete three
different sentences you want to write
this down the first sentence you look at
yourself and you say your name so you
say Louis and you complete this is I'm
proud that you and find seven different
things every day to celebrate yourself
for seven different each day you can do
the same thing you did the day before
but each they do seven different things
to be proud of the second sentence is
going to knock you down a little bit
it's gonna come from your gut Louis I
forgive you for and cut the shackles to
blame shame guilt regret and anger in
that sentence you cut those five
shackles not the first day maybe not the
third day but by the 21st day by the
thirteenth day you'll feel some relief
so Louis I forgive you for and go back
five years 15 years 20 years do that
forgive you fit for that thing don't
nobody know about but you go ahead and
cut those shackles because if you can
still think about it is filling your
energy space and then the third sentence
is Louis I come
to you that before you make a commitment
to anybody else throughout your day you
make seven commitments to you so the
first sentence is I'm proud that you
you're celebrating yourself first we are
under celebrated as a society we look
for acknowledgement they enter they
interviewed 100 executives that all made
over a quarter of a million dollars and
said would you like a 5% raise next year
or would you rather be told thank you
more often 100 percent 100 percent said
keep your money I'd rather hear thank
you so we're under celebrated but first
celebrate you be the example when I was
on Oprah when she said what are you
doing I recognize that I'm the example
of how the rest of the world is supposed
to treat me and it's my job to give the
world the best example of how I like to
be treated right so celebrate yourself
forgive yourself cut the shackles and
then commit to yourself before you
commit to anyone else that right there
powerful that right there will begin to
fill your cup up to get to your
something we talk about making your dash
dance point one you got to be willing to
do it afraid so you might be waiting for
the fear to stop Lisa I heard this so
much I'm Lisa I'm afraid what do I do
do it anyway Lisa I'm afraid I don't
quite know if I should move move anyway
I don't know if I should leap leap
afraid and then gather your courage on
the way down and if you don't get it
before you hit you don't hit anyway I'd
rather die leaping then on the edge
figuring out how to get the courage to
leap yes yes yes yes so many times we're
waiting we're waiting I'm waiting I'm
waiting to get something like I see your
hands going up you guys know official
truth you can raise your hand just like
we did on day zero you're just kind of
waiting you're waiting to get everything
in order you're waiting you're waiting
so that everything is is Inuits together
you're waiting to not be afraid you're
waiting to have the courage you're
waiting to have all the money you're
waiting to lose weight please see if I
waited to release my unwanted pounds
before I got in front of you Lisa
Nichols would be the
secret yes yes I thought how about I
just leave with my imperfection and then
find my form of perfecting my
imperfection while I'm sorry how about I
do that how about I'm not how about you
not wait to get it right you look at you
figure out how does it look doing it
wrong how does that look because you're
80% of right is somebody else's hundred
and fifty nine percent of what they
needed yes yes and what you want to do
it right and you want to wait too you're
not afraid you want to wait you have all
together oh you made it about you again
see Nelson Mandela did it he just did it
not knowing if you were right Mahatma
Gandhi just did it not knowing if it
were right mother Teresa just did it not
looking for affirmation or confirmation
is this right Martin Luther King did it
not even knowing if it would happen
before his life ended
what are you waiting on are you willing
to do it afraid are you willing to do it
knowing that you got so much work to do
to get it better to get it more perfect
but are you willing to do it inside your
imperfection do you realize it in your
imperfection you're perfect for the job
thank you guys so much you are a mess no
what did you think when we take this
video you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
let me know that in the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I don't
want to give a quick shout out to
Melissa Alexandra Melissa thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and doing that awesome
rubber view on your YouTube channel
surrounded I really need to support
being so blessed you enjoyed it in this
video I'm going to be going over the
book yo one word by Evan Carmichael this
is a book that I really really enjoyed
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is let's love
[Music]